well last week was you might say
eventful it began with three major
medical organizations calling for the
prosecution of high-profile social media
personalities who have been reporting on
and criticizing so-called gender
affirming care
um having extremely well-funded and
Powerful medical associations not so
subtly single me out and call for my
arrest would have been enough activity
for one week as far as I'm concerned but
very next day Media Matters launched
their most extensive hit piece against
me Edna transparent attempt to derail
our campaign against gender ideology and
while this was all going on we were also
in the first week of our what is a woman
College Tour where throngs of protesters
complain that my presence was
destabilizing their existence and
responded by defiantly singing Bohemian
Rhapsody in a vocal performance that
resembled the sound of seven thousand
chickens choking to death all at once
and then came the big win on Friday uh
the Capstone to all these events at the
end of a week where I think our enemies
thought that they landed a knockout blow
it was announced by Vanderbilt in a
letter to State lawmakers that they
would be pausing all gender transition
procedures on minors so they caved they
surrendered for perhaps
the first time in recent memory anyway a
left-wing Institution
caved to pressure from the right
very rarely does that happen but we beat
them battle is not close to over the
Fight Continues of course as we now move
on to to make gender transitions on
miners illegal across the entire State
and then we move across the entire
country but this was a major victory and
I think perhaps
in some ways unprecedented
and we'll have much more to say about it
in a few minutes but the week was not
over with the Vanderbilt news
that night
Jon Stewart opened the second season of
his Apple TV show Even though nobody
watched the first season he got a second
season anyway a little bit more of that
left-wing privilege that he's benefiting
from
um most people didn't even know that the
first season happened but it did did
season two episode one comes along and
focuses on the topic of gender
um it is in effect Jon Stewart's
response to our documentary what is a
woman and even features a brief clip of
the film the left has hailed this
episode as the ultimate takedown of the
conservative conspiracy theory that
women don't have penises this is the it
just demolishes all of us we're told
so to begin the show today we're going
to go through
what are being celebrated as the most
compelling and persuasive moments from
this episode
and we will show that Jon Stewart is a
shallow spineless left-wing hack who has
long had the reputation as a free
thinker and a sort of bold comedic mind
even though he is always simply adopted
the mainstream corporate position on
literally every topic
and that's what he's done now on gender
so we start with a clip shared by the
show's Twitter account and the the
caption of this clip on their Twitter
account was what is a woman it's a
question that suddenly is everywhere and
it turns out the answer is complicated
John breaks down the gender binary and
gender Spectrum in this week's episode
we are in a new dawn of gender and sex
complexity where those who don't fit
into a simple binary are meant to be
seen with Humanity
it wasn't always like this people as
recently as let's say the 1990s early
2000s people were making reductive jokes
about the subject
what can I say the joke rhymed
it would be sad to see Jon Stewart
apologizing for his past jokes
disavowing his previous belief that men
can't have babies and groveling for
acceptance from a bunch of purple-haired
22 year olds but you must realize that
Jon Stewart has always been a pathetic
fraud this is fully in keeping with his
brand it's it's still a sickening
stomach churning display of
self-debasement as revolting and
perverse as watching someone eat
themselves on camera but it's exactly
what you ought to expect from a lifelong
shill let's continue
any moment of progressive visibility
will be met with a vicious backlash
there are two genders there are two
genders and everyone knows it eight but
two genders
that last guy sounded like it's an
emergency and we're running out of
genders everyone
they're able to do genders
so here you see uh the attempt to make a
completely self-evident and obvious
statement seem absurd the audience with
the enhancement of a laugh track giggles
at the statement that there are only two
genders like this is the move if you
just laugh at something then that
automatically makes it laughable
expecting us to believe that the claim
is funny just because they're laughing
at it
but they can't make this objectively
correct statement funny by laughing
about it any more than they can make a
statement like the world is round or Jon
Stewart is a gutless smirking slug funny
by laughing about it these are all just
simply objective self-evident
observations about the physical world
it's really not funny at all but let's
uh continue along
the point is clear
the human race is defined by a simple
binary a black and white understanding
there are men and there are women and
never the twain shall meet Trump is an
alpha male well okay yes there are
obviously men who are more man than
other men but that's an aberration Vader
gamma okay
there's an entire Greek alphabet a
Continuum of masculinity but that
doesn't mean cuck Pajama Boy of soy boy
girly man
I hope the children are out of the room
clearly masculinity appears to be on a
dimmer not an on off switch but ladies
are different I was a big tomboy these
purple-haired angry freaks rabid
feminist cat lady hi Roman bimbos pretty
girly girl
my God
what a cruise line Buffet of the
gradients in American gender expression
turns out there's a lot of non-binary
happening between the binaries
this is this is Johnson by the way just
he this is this he goes back to the
Daily Show just play a clip of someone
saying something normal and then mug for
the camera like it's you know the
episode an episode of The Office just
someone says something normal and you
look at the camera like
and then that's that's the joke it's
like automatically that thing is now
funny but these are all just
descriptions of personality traits and
most of them are labels used to describe
the same sorts of people so
how does this at all even slightly call
into question the existence of the
manned woman binary nobody ever said
John that every man is exactly the same
as every other man or that every woman
is the same as every other woman squares
can also come in many different shapes
and colors and rather many different
sizes and colors not shapes that's the
point a square is still a square so you
can color a different color you can have
a big square a little square there are
lots of different ways you can describe
squares depending on how you decorate
them but a square is still Square you
can do a lot of interesting things with
a square you can't make it a circle is
the point
so is that really the best that Stuart
can do just like pointing out that there
are different personality traits
different ways that you can describe uh
individual men different insults you can
use against individual women that's what
is that it is that all you have
is that what the left considers some
kind of definitive Smackdown of the
gender binary surely he must have more
in his Arsenal he doesn't of course but
we'll keep watching anyway
that hasn't stopped the traditionalists
from deploying their newest weapon in
the culture war arsenal the obvious
gotcha question the real basic question
what is a woman can you provide a
definition for the word woman for all of
recorded history people have known what
a woman is
it was simple until like a year ago the
answer to what is a woman has always
been the same it's a a woman is a
deformity that occurred in the ordinary
course of nature
foreign
I apologize that's I'm sorry that's not
what I meant I meant a woman is a person
who has no legal existence once married
that's I'm sorry that's that's early
American coverture law that's that's not
right no the throughout history it's not
a gotcha question a woman is 30 shekels
that's I'm sorry
I'm sorry that's Leviticus
yes John those are different things that
different people and institutions have
said about women over the course of
history but what is your point Aristotle
and the author of Leviticus and everyone
else that you might name from ancient
history all agreed on what a woman is
fundamentally and physically they all
agreed that a woman can be defined
because if they didn't then they
couldn't have said anything about women
in the first place say see John that's
what you're not feared not understanding
it you can't even talk about them you
can't say anything about them at all
unless there's some shared understanding
of what this entity is
you know in 2020 there were over a
thousand significant online data
breaches in the U.S which left almost
156 million people's records exposed
that was all in one year that includes
sense of information related to your
children now you wouldn't let your kids
walk home from school without telling
them not to talk to strangers or get
into any windowless Vans but you let
them go online every day without a VPN
to protect your family's privacy when
they go online you've got to use
expressvpn internet service providers
know every single website you visit isps
can sell this information to ad
companies and Tech Giants who then use
your data to Target you you really want
all these advertisers knowing who's in
your household what your kids like to
watch How to Target them with whatever
they're you know looking to sell
expressvpn protects your privacy without
slowing your connection no matter how
many users are in your household unlike
other vpns they don't even realize you
have it on it's so easy to use just
download the app on your phone or
computer tap one button and you're
protected simple as that no one in your
family is too old or too young to figure
out how to use it so secure your
family's online activity by visual
expressvpn.com Matt Walsh show today use
my link and you can get an extra three
months free expressvpn.com Matt walshow
expressvpn.com Matt Walsh show
what you're proving is that over history
people have had different ideas about
the legal standing of women about their
place in society and so on and so on but
you haven't proved that there was ever
at any time ever in history ever until
just now even the slightest disagreement
on the definition of the word
no indeed you've proven the opposite if
anything
I mean there are people who would say
different things about Jon Stewart some
people would say he's a comedic genius
on the other hand people with
functioning brains say that he's a bland
boring chump desperate for approval
these are all adjectives some of them
more accurate than others
they don't make Jon Stewart into some
kind of abstract undefinable entity
who's very objective existence is now Up
For Debate
but Stuart isn't done here he also
interviews Leslie Rutledge who's the
Arkansas attorney general and a great
American who's helped to spearhead the
efforts in her state to make it illegal
to sexually mutilate children
yet not every Great American is
necessarily equipped to successfully
respond to a partisan hack like Stuart
while the cameras are rolling okay not
everyone is is going to be good in that
context and unfortunately uh it doesn't
seem like Rutledge really is which is
exactly why she was chosen for this
segment but let's watch a little bit of
this
why would the state of Arkansas step in
to override
parents
Physicians
psychiatrists
endocrinologists who have developed
guidelines why would you override those
guidelines
well I think it's important that all of
those Physicians all of those experts
for every single one of them there's an
expert that says we don't need to allow
children to be able to take those
medications that there are many
incidences where but you know that's not
true you know it's not for everyone
there's one there's these are the
established well I don't know that
that's not true I don't know that then
why would you why would you pass a law
then if you don't if you don't know that
that's true wouldn't you well I know
that there are doctors and that we had
plenty of people come and testify before
our legislature who said that uh you
know we have 98 of the young people who
have gender dysphoria
that they are able to move past that and
once they have the the help that they
need no longer suffer from gender
dysphoria 98 without that medical
treatment that's an incredibly made up
figure that's that doesn't comport with
any of the studies or documentation that
exists from these medical organizations
what what Medical Association are you
talking about of these doctors well we
have all of that in our uh legislative
history and we'll be glad to provide
that to you
okay Jon Stewart was of course extremely
careful about which conservative he
invited to speak to him about this issue
um I don't think I'm
inflating myself in any respect by
saying that I am
primarily the one who's brought the what
is a woman question to the Forefront and
yet Stewart didn't reach out to me for
an interview if he had I would have
eagerly accepted and here's how I would
have responded instead of making the
mistake of getting into a credentialism
contest as Rutledge does here takes the
bait once you do that it's over okay
that's that's all this conversation is
now
I would have said something like this
John you're coming out of the gate with
appeals to Authority because you don't
have any thoughts of your own that's the
first problem there was a time when a
similar appeal to Authority could have
been used to prove that the Earth is the
center of the universe or that
bloodletting is the cure for every known
disease okay there was a time when every
medical expert in the world would have
told you that if you want to cure any
disease cut yourself open and Bleed It
Out
in this case your brainless appeals to
Authority are even more asinine because
the authorities you mention all have an
obvious Financial stake in the very
medical practices you're seeking to
justify so what you're telling me is
that people who make millions of dollars
mutilating kids all say it's a good idea
to mutilate kids wow breaking news the
tobacco industry also has funded studies
showing that smoking isn't so bad for
you will you be citing those on your
next show John
but this is all beside the point
the burden of proof is not on me to
explain to you why we shouldn't castrate
and sterilize children you guys are the
ones coming along out of nowhere
demanding that we start engaging in
those kinds of horrific practices so you
tell me what your evidence is what
studies are you talking about tell me
John which credible long-term studies
prove that it's a good idea to castrate
a mutilated kids which ones
which ones here I'll help you there are
none they don't exist
these medical institutions don't have
studies to support their practices our
kids are the study this current
generation is the guinea pig the lab
rats
that's the part you're leaving out you
sycophantic gas bag
now I'd like to tell you that this
conversation progresses from here but it
really doesn't Stewart spends the entire
interview obsessing over the guidelines
of medical organizations that's the only
thing they talk about so well this
organization said that we should do it
so we should
that's literally all he has that's it
his whole case comes down to
um
these people said we should castrate
kids
which people uh well the people who make
billions of dollars doing it
oh great good to know
he also lies of course and misrepresents
the data let's check that out
I've got some bad news for you
parents with children who have gender
dysphoria have lost children
to suicide and depression and they
absolutely because it's acute
and so these mainstream medical
organizations have developed guidelines
through peer-reviewed data and studies
and through those guidelines they've
improved mental health outcomes
what data is that John what are you
talking about you're saying that there
is data showing that a child's long-term
mental health is improved by castrating
and sterilizing and mutilating him
which data exactly is that where is that
data can you cite it
see Leslie Rutledge unfortunately never
flips it around on him he's very lucky
that she never thinks to say what what
are you talking about could what do you
can you show me
what are you talking about can you
provide an example can you say anything
about it other than insisting that it
exists
no you can't because it doesn't exist it
never has existed and it never will
you're lying
and fortunately for you your guests
didn't call you out on that
but I will and I do it to your face if
you had the courage to sit down with
someone who won't be so easily
railroaded
but in some ways I'm grateful for the
Jon Stewart episode he's you know he's
grateful for it because it's the first
time anyone has paid attention to him in
like eight years I'm grateful because
it's being heralded as the the best
defense of gender ideology ever put to
film
and yet it's laughably weak and can be
dismantled with almost no effort at all
and that really tells you everything you
need to know
about gender ideology
if you want to join my exclusive fan
base or a cult as really as that's what
it is where Joy we're forming a cult
then all you gotta do is click the
Subscribe button and ring the bell below
this video to stay up to date with all
my content and if you want even more you
can watch or listen to my show at the
daily wire.com Spotify or apple podcast
looking forward to welcoming you to the
Sweet Baby gang